Speaker 1: Sometimes you can sort of feel
like you're riding a propaganda wave from
right wing media.
One example would be the hydroxy chloroquine
wave where it built and built and built, where
everybody was talking about it, Fox News and
Donald Trump and everybody hydroxy hydroxy.
And then all of a sudden the wave crashes
and that's it.
Hydroxy chloroquine.
Nobody ever talks about it again.
And right now, the propaganda wave is around
the Regeneron monoclonal antibody treatment
for covid as an alternative to the vaccine,
as something that tells us you don't really
have to worry that much because we've got
the monoclonal antibodies available for whoever
needs them.
And case in point, on Fox and Friends, one
of the three hosts, Ainslee Erhart, big purveyor
of propaganda, falsely claimed that since
you can get the Regeneron treatment after
getting infected, that's basically like getting
vaccinated.
Now, that's completely untrue.
Again, the context of the clip is Republican
Governor Greg Abbott, who tested positive
in Texas.
We covered that story, talked about it.
Let's let's listen to what Ainslee Arehart
had to say.
You know,
Speaker 2: it's interesting, Greg Abbott,
we he's in our prayers this morning because
he announced that he tested positive for covid
yesterday.
He has been vaccinated and still got covid.
But I think he's doing OK.
He's by the
Speaker 1: way, that's always like a slight
hit at the vaccine, vaccinated and still got
it,
Speaker 2: getting the Regeneron no symptoms,
he said.
What's interesting, though, is if you don't
get vaccinated and you go to the hospital,
most of the time you're going to get Regeneron.
But Regeneron, are the antibodies basically
still getting vaccinated because they're sticking
you with an antibody.
Speaker 1: But right.
Regeneron is the antibodies.
So you're still basically getting vaccinated
because they're sticking you with the antibodies
Speaker 2: to the virus.
Speaker 4: So so guess what they're doing
in this terribly run city?
They are deciding you can't go to places,
you can't go to movies, you can't go to bars,
you can't go to restaurants, you can't go
to gyms, can't go to anything unless you have
your vaccination cards.
Right, which takes a dollar to make a knockoff
card or.
Yeah, there's a different look
Speaker 1: at look at Brian Kilmeade mentioning,
by the way, you can make a fake vaccination
card for a dollar.
That's a crime.
We'll get back to that.
But this is becoming all the rage.
Here is Sean Hannity on Fox News last night.
He's trying to talk about monoclonal antibodies.
He calls them monoclonal antibodies, very
aggressive.
Speaker 4: Who builds these model colonial
antibody centers?
Speaker 1: It's a big issue of colonization,
guys, actually, it's it's a big, big thing.
OK, so let's talk about it now.
They're saying vaccine.
What about the Regeneron treatment?
So first of all, the Regeneron treatment is
only emergency use authorized by the FDA.
All of these people saying, listen, if I get
sick, I'll get the antibodies, and that's
safer than an experimental, unapproved covid
vaccine.
The vaccine is authorized by the FDA under
an emergency use authorization.
It's not fully authorized.
The Regeneron monoclonal antibody treatment
is likewise authorized under emergency use.
If you look at the fact sheet, it says, is
this approved by the FDA to treat or prevent
covid?
And the answer is no.
This is an investigational drug.
It is not currently FDA approved to treat
or prevent any disease or condition included,
including covid-19.
The Regeneron treatment is only authorized
under NCUA and it also says it is not a replacement
for vaccination against covid-19 in the same
fact sheet.
It says post exposure prophylaxis with the
antibody treatment is not a substitute for
vaccination against covid-19.
So this is just the new thing.
It's the new fad.
It's the new propaganda wave that they're
riding, Regeneron, Regeneron.
And by the way, it just so happens that a
whole bunch of elected officials have financial
interests in Regeneron.
So make of that what you will.
We're not necessarily saying anything about
that, but that that's another thing.
Last thing I want to play again for you, this
is Brian Kilmeade mentioning you can get a
fake vaccine card for a dollar or
Speaker 4: anything unless you have your vaccination
cards right.
Which takes a dollar to make a knockoff card.
Oh, yeah, there's a difference.
Speaker 1: So there is Brian Kilmeade talking
about it's cheap to get a fake vaccine card.
Now, remember, the vaccine itself is free,
OK?
So no matter how little you pay for a fake
vaccine card, the vaccine, it's safe, is free,
and the paper won't protect you.
The actual vaccine will.
But I want to remind people it is a crime
to have to make or present for use a fake
CDC vaccination card.
The unauthorized use of an official government
agency SEAL, like the CDC or the HHS, is a
crime.
It may be punishable under Title 18 of USC,
Section Ten, Seventeen and other applicable
laws.
If you believe or you know or have information
about somebody faking a vaccine card particularly,
and then using it for something, we're only
vaccinated people are supposed to be or do
or whatever the case may be.
You can call one 800 HHS tips or you can go
to the Internet Crime Complaint Center at
Icey three gov.
You can also call your local district attorney,
state attorney general.
You can try local police.
How much they'll know what to do, I don't
really know.
You might also end up with an anti VAX police
officer taking your call.
Who the hell knows?
But the point here is it's against the law
and you can report it.
Eight hundred tips or I see three dot gov.